in this video today we will take a break
from the monsterverse and godzilla
versus kong breakdown videos
and dive into the world of the scps and
most specifically the gods of the scp
universe
there are many deities and gods in this
franchise and many of them share
unimaginable power that can put other
monsters
from other universes to shame they are
reality
vendors universal manipulators and
multiversal entities
we also know that there are a group of
entities called the scp
old gods and that list will be on
another video
but in this one we will list out the
very powerful deities in this franchise
which might also include a few of the
old gods as well as
new ones so let's get down to it
number one the scarlet king often
considered as one of the most dangerous
beings in the multiverse
the scarlet king is an eldritch god
formed as a manifestation of the tension
between the modern world
and the pre-modern world and the rage it
creates
he is one of the candidates to be
considered as scp-001
known initially by his birth name kalhak
the red shah or the red khan he was the
only one of his siblings to possess
self-awareness
he declared war on creation itself with
the goal of ending everything including
the creator and himself
he is the main reason the scp foundation
was created
to prevent him from coming here into
this universe he is always depicted as a
huge
red demonic figure that wears a gold
crown his status towards reality is so
dangerous that the scp foundation had to
join forces
with other foundations and organizations
to keep him in check
and also to keep the cult of the scarlet
king in check so yeah this god is one of
the most powerful he'll hear
number 2 creator god 343
scp-343 is a male seemingly raised less
humanoid in appearance with apparent
omnipotence
scp-343 was discovered walking the
streets of prague
and detained after a staff member
witnessed him disappear from the streets
and reappear on a rooftop
scp-343 is detained willingly in his
chamber
as containment has proved impossible
scp-343 clinically
named god by the staff here looks like
an older man although his features are
different to each observer
in one of the interviews with him he
claimed outright to be the creator of
the universe himself
scp-343 was involved with neutralizing
scp-239
which was a small girl that can change
reality he managed to halt her changes
but didn't seem to be all powerful
or maybe not willing enough to show all
of his power
number three yeah the ball yelled about
is often considered a blind creature
driven by pure instinct
he is usually accompanied by six beings
called arkhans
which are faceless manifestations of
primordial chaos
it is believed that life is an
unintentional
byproduct that is exhaled by the old god
after devouring other gods and stars
yeldebath doesn't have a specific scp
designation as
most of the knowledge of himself
originates from psychic scriptures
and religious texts at some point of
time mccannis
the deity worshipped by the church of
the broken god engaged the elder both in
a biblical battle
over the fate of humanity the battle
ended with mcconnell
sealing yelled about away but breaking
into pieces himself
number four makani according to the
myths mekane shared dominion over
humanity with yaldabaoth
the broken god representing intellect
and progress while the other represented
instinct
and the more animalistic side of the
humans also known as the broken god or
wan
he is an ancient and mysterious deity in
the universe of the scp foundation
who is worshipped by the church of the
broken god depicted as a cybernetic god
made of metal
referred to as a male with powers beyond
comprehension
equal in power to socket gods such as
yaldabaoth who is capable of manifesting
and destroying all levels of existence
in a multiverse it houses over 196
thousand
885 spatial dimensions and countless
higher dimensions that reside
within the unobservable dimensions
number five cigar god also known as
scp-3004-1
it is a key to class scp that refers to
a series of violent
anomalous events occurring in christian
communities caused by the instances of
scp-3004-2 a species of cicada
resembling the extinct
cicada lugulente made up of wood and
glass
scp-3004-1 or the cigar god needs
faith to survive and can be weakened if
the religion that nourishes it is
completely destroyed
although it can move on to another
religion if this happens
it also cannot manifest itself within
our reality without enough faith
rituals are used to fuel scp-3004-1
an entity existing in a dimension
simultaneously within
and above baseline reality a god-like
being that believes itself to be the
christian god itself
it has various powers like reality
warping mind and biological manipulation
and can cause an end of the world event
number six kali scp-029 is a killer
class
scp contained by the scp foundation she
is an entity
which takes the shape of a young asiatic
indian female
and is the leader of a group of gangster
thuggy
cultists which referred to her as the
daughter of darkness
she is referred to as a god and believed
to be the incarnation of the hindu
goddess kali
the goddess of time and death no males
are permitted to enter her containment
as any male within her presence will
fall under her spell and become willing
to kill
to help her in her ultimate goals which
is to sacrifice one million souls in
order to raise and
resurrect the goddess kali and in the
world
over 80 of her pigmentation is true
black in color while the rest of her
skin
has a complete lack of melanin to the
point of albinism
her eyes are also dark black in color
she is very strange
indeed number seven the deer
also known as the deer from saturn
scp-2845 is a quarterback entity
measuring 2.9 meters in height
at the shoulder and weighing 815
kilograms
a sinus neck generally held in an
upright position
extends a further half a meter in height
terminating in a head
with a human facial feature and scp-2845
possesses antlers measuring 4.8 meters
in all directions
antlers are white and black in
coloration and have not been observed to
shed
it is capable of transmutations and
reconstructions when needed
this property manifests at its own will
the maximum power of this
entity's ability is anonymous the stack
is a god
and it's not just a local petty god it
is not one of the mild gods of earth but
a very powerful entity
scp-2845 is one of the few anomalies
where the foundation has looked for help
outside of its ranks
for it in order to contain the threat
number eight the hang
king also designated as scp-2264-5
the hanged king is a very powerful being
in the universe of the scp foundation
he is the monarch of a distant realm of
alagadda
and is considered as one of the most
powerful entities in the multiverse
although not really a god he is termed
as a deity of the other parallel
universe
his origins are vague some stating that
he was a king
that was betrayed by his people and came
back from the dead as a very powerful
deity
his true powers is yet unknown but it is
said that he could rival
yell the both and mekane as well making
him one of the most powerful entities in
the multiverse of the scp foundation
number nine scp-3999
this near-all-powerful entity designated
as scp-399
is a reality bending god defying
description and motive
utter void and chaos itself it is an
ancient monstrosity that had
the ability to also interest reality
around it it is undoubtedly one of the
most powerful entities in the universe
and is held bent on destroying
everything and recreating it
with an intent to inflict pain on a
singular person
a researcher of the scp foundation
surprisingly
but the one weakness it has is that it
must born with a living being
in order to exist and when that person
the researcher kills himself
he also kills scp-399 as well
and erases everything that the sap has
done
all of the reality warping and
manipulation all of
his work and so with that we come to the
end of the video on the nine powerful
gods and deities
from the scp foundation universe do let
us know your pick
and what other gods we might have left
out since
the scp is a very vast universe a very
vast topic
which evolves practically every day with
new entries
anyway do hit that like button for
support smash that subscribe button to
be a part of the mind cue family
and smash or slap the notification bell
for regular updates on monster content
right here on
mind cue take care fam